Speaker 1: Last week, I told you about a
young anti VAX nurse who got covid and died.
And I told you I take no pleasure in
that, although some people called in
and said they do take pleasure in that.
We now have another one of these examples.
Linda Zirkin, former born selectman,
dies of complications of covid-19.
Linda Zohn remembered as a staunch conservative,
well respected educator and friend to many in
the town of Bourne, Massachusetts, died on
Friday due to complications of covid-19.
Zurin, 70, died at Brigham and Women's Hospital
in Boston of severe complications caused by covid.
She was brought from Cape Cod by mid
flight to the hospital in early June
and had been in a coma on a ventilator until her
death. She was not vaccinated against covid-19,
according to a close friend and one of
her neighbors. The article includes a
picture of Linda Urn with a Trump flag
and a Magga hat. From November of twenty
nineteen, Xi'an was known for volunteering
on various boards and committees in town.
She served three terms on the Board of Selectmen,
et cetera, et cetera. On the political side, she
was president of the Chapter nine Massachusetts
Republican Assembly. Zurin was one of the first
members of the United Kape Patriots. She was often
seen hold o frequently held Trump standouts on the
board rotary. I've driven by that. I've driven
by that one going to Martha's Vineyard. That's
interesting. She was often seen holding a Trump
supporter support poster as motorists drove by
honking in support or against langue was one of
four people. Adam Lang, according to Adam Lang,
Lang was one of four people who protested
last week in opposition to the State Vax bus,
which distributes covid-19 vaccines when it
arrived in Provincetown. So some people react to
this by saying, who cares? Or even good, that's
not. My reaction, I find this to be a tragedy,
a tragedy of disinformation and misinformation,
some react by saying we should refuse
health insurance coverage to people who refuse
to get vaccinated. Some people react by saying
we should refuse treatment to these people, which
I don't think you can do. That would violate the
Hippocratic Oath that medical professionals take.
Others say we should charge these people more and
there may be something there. I mean, listen,
when you look at when you look at life insurance,
you pay more if you're a smoker, for example.
So it's not without precedent that I don't know,
maybe we look at a higher health insurance rate
for people who choose not to get vaccinated.
There are serious moral questions about it. There
are serious legal questions about it. For me, the
solution is we just find a way to get these people
vaccinated. That's really where I am. And maybe I
maybe I have too much empathy. I don't know. But
another victim of anti Voxer ism, the anti Voxer,
has died and it's hard to feel good about
it. And even if you don't care about her,
how many people could she have infected
who were vaccinated either due to
low immunity as a result of
being immunocompromised or for
whatever other reason? For me, there's
really nothing to be happy about here.